[موسيقى]
لكن هذه الضوابط هي اشبه بشبكه وليست
جدارا منيعه لذلك عمدت ايران الى شراء تلك
القطع بصوره النمطيه عبر اللجوء الى وكلاء
لشراء الاجزاء ربما عبر احد الموزعين في
بلد اخر لذلك فان قضيه حصول ايران على تلك
الاجزاء لم تلقى الاهتمام الكافي الذي
يتعين له عندما يحدث شيء من ذلك القدير
اجزاء السيارات
[موسيقى]
حكومه الولايات المتحده برمتها قادره
للغايه على معرفه الشبكات وشبكات للتجار
وشبكات التهريب وطريقه عملها واماكن
موضوعها وهويه المتورطين وكيف انتهى
المطاف بهذه الاجزاء في ايران وحسب ما
اعرفه فاذا الشركات تبدي تعاونا لانها
عرضه في الولايات المتحده على وجه التحديد
بغرامات نظيره تزويد او بيع اجزاء تصل في
نهايه الامر الى ايران
[موسيقى]
شوهدت عده حالات فريده توضح كيفيه التمكن
حكومه الولايات المتحده من تحديد الشبكات
التجار الايرانيه
عن تحديد الاشخاص المتورطين في ظهران على
سبيل المثال والشركات المنخرطه ويمكنهم
البحث مباشره عبر اجزاء من اوروبا ما اذا
كان هناك عميل ايراني في الولايات المتحده
ثم شحنها بطريقه قانونيه الى ايران
[موسيقى]